He’s waiting for you in the dark.
He sits, cross-legged, still as a placid lake
and patient as a praying monk six feet deep
in meditation.
He’s been like this for so long.
His body oil-slicked with deadly black grease,
skin ancient and haggard, eyes black and flat
with the kind of calm you only find in crawling
insects and Great White Sharks.
His lipless mouth is stretched across his
jawbone in an ugly, black rictus.
He may be an Old Man, but trust us, he’s
got plenty of new tricks he’d love to show
you.
He sat in the loneliest place in the world:
The deep, dark bowels of an SCP Foundation
containment site, surrounded by a complex
confluence of containment measures: Different
shapes, running liquids, bright lights, the
kind of steel so thick a nuclear weapon would
only leave it scuffed.
All the things that had a tendency to...
Confuse him.
Because that’s all they ever did.
The Old Man laughed to himself, very quietly.
All the people out there are so scared of
him because of one immutable fact: He isn’t
trapped here, he’s just resting.
By virtue of his unique anomalous abilities
- to pass through solids at will and resist
any form of physical damage they can dole
out - there is no way to really contain him
like all the others.
All the SCP Foundation could hope to do was
make leaving inconvenient enough for him to
make his little adventures on the outside
less appealing than just sitting around, doing
nothing.
After all, he had all the time in the world,
and when you always have a “Later”, there’s
a lot less pressure to do anything now.
But like all thinking creatures - And please,
be aware that SCP-106, the wretched, terrifying
Old Man, is very much a thinking creature
- he was subject to occasional boredom.
And when most people are bored, they might
play a video game, watch a few YouTube videos,
or rewatch It’s Always Sunny In Philadelphia
for the fifth time.
But for the Old Man, killing boredom involved...
Well, killing people.
But not just killing people, of course.
Truth be told, for him, killing was really
the least entertaining part of the whole affair.
The screams?
The begging?
The desperate pleas?
Warm tears on shaking cheeks?
Convulsions of pain?
Cold sweats?
Fear so intense it gives way to gibbering
madness?
That dull sheen of dead hope in their eyes
when they then realize that their doom is
inevitable, and that he, their captor, their
torturer, would decide the exact moment they
slipped into the void?
Oh, that was what he lived for - If you could
call what the Old Man did Living.
He cracked his neck and licked his teeth.
Was he salivating?
All those thoughts about pain seemed to have
got him worked up.
He could feel the distant thumping of his
heart.
Old, black blood pumping through the dusty
corridors of his vascular system.
Synapses booming and sparking with excitement
at the thought of plumbing new depths of human
misery, like a scholar of suffering, a pioneer
of pain.
All those silly Foundation drones, with the
audacity to think they’re in control.
He’d teach them to scream again...
Meanwhile, in the control room for the Old
Man’s containment chamber, all hell was
breaking loose.
Monitors on the monster’s vitals were all
spiking: Heart and brain activity peaked,
just as they always did before the Old Man
decided to get active.
Cameras in his containment chamber showed
him rising steadily to his feet, cracking
his joints, limbering up.
His body started to produce that terrible
corrosive mucus at an accelerated rate, pooling
around his feet and unleashing squalls of
noxious fumes as it melted into the floor.
Years of Foundation testing, and they still
couldn’t find any material that could withstand
that vile black slop...
As the Old Man began strolling towards the
wall, a containment specialist in the control
room grabbed a nearby phone and sounded the
alarm for the containment breach.
They needed a Mobile Task Force and every
guard on site mobilized to tackle 106 before
he got into the facility proper and started
causing havoc.
They couldn’t risk it escaping, either - The
infamous incident when the Old Man escaped
for a Halloween massacre still haunted the
nightmares of many a staff member.
He had to be stopped - Now!
A small fighting force was quickly armed and
assembled, along with armor and several high-intensity
portable lights to hopefully slow the monster
down in time for them to grab a D-Class and
set up the femur breaker.
By the time they all reached the hallway they
intended to use as a choke point for the escape,
the Old Man was already half way through the
outer layer of defence, phasing through the
wall with that same terrible, manic grin he
always had when he was about to inflict terrible
violence for the sheer fun of it.
The guards and task force members trained
their lights and weapons on him.
All of them had seen terrible things on the
job - the kind of things that would saddle
almost anyone with a lifetime of trauma - but
almost nothing compared to the horror of direct
engagement during a 106 containment breach.
That terrible old coffin dodger was Hell on
two legs.
When they discovered, to their horror, that
the lights didn’t seem to be slowing him
down as much as anticipated, they fell back
on Plan B: That B standing for, “Blast the
living hell out of him with everything they
had.”
The personnel opened fire, pumping round after
round into his dark form.
While each gave a loud, meaty splatter, the
Old Man didn’t even flinch.
When he was close enough, all those months
of lethargy gave way to sudden, deadly speed.
In many ways, the Old Man was like a crocodile.
A fierce and intelligent ambush predator who
conserved his energy wisely.
He could seem so deceptively languid that
you could easily mistake him for something
slow and harmless.
But when you got within arm’s reach, the
sudden quickness and ferocity would take you
off guard.
And by then, it’s already too late.
Within thirty seconds, the Old Man was the
only thing left alive in that hallway.
All the guards and Task Force operatives sent
to slow him down lay dead, dripping with his
black mucus.
There was silence, save for the quiet fizzing
of the mucus eating into their clothes and
skin.
The Old Man sighed.
How boring.
He’d killed so many people now, it all started
to seem a little...
Samey.
How many screams could you hear before they
all just blended into a single shrill whine?
You can get sick of even your favorite meal
if you eat it too often.
But that didn’t matter.
The Old Man had a different order of business
today: He happened to be inside an SCP Foundation
containment facility, filled with so many
fascinating specimens of non-human entities
that the one they called SCP-106 simply couldn’t
wait to torture.
He’d only met a small portion of the ones
they had contained here, but given what a
fascinating experience his past attack on
his fellow anomalies was, he couldn’t wait
to meet some more.
Meanwhile, the site’s top brass did all
they could to try to mobilize a second response
to the rogue senior citizen from hell currently
strolling through their high-security containment
facility.
Could they get in contact with other Mobile
Task Forces deployed in the area?
Maybe they could get Hammer Down or Samsara
in on this mess before anything got really
out of hand?
The Old Man seemed more intent on something
this time, they suspected even the femur breaker
might not work in luring him back until he
claimed whatever he deemed to be his prize.
Maybe they should contact the O5 Council...
Security guards were tracking 106’s progress
through the facility via their vast networks
of security cameras.
They warned any research, administration,
and janitorial staff to clear out of his path,
unless they felt like being tortured to death.
He hadn’t dragged anyone into his pocket
dimension yet, so whoever that privilege was
reserved for would probably be getting a particular
sticky experience.
They could only speculate as to the silent
beast’s intentions.
One guard noticed something.
When cross-referencing 106’s movements with
a map of the facility, they were able to triangulate
where he was heading: Straight for the containment
chamber of SCP-096.
The guard’s lips curled into a slight smile,
thinking, “If one of you freaks can actually
kill the other, maybe something positive will
come out of this disaster...”
The Old Man was having a stroll down memory
lane.
The time prior, when he broke out of his cell
and decided to hassle his fellow intimates
was certainly eventful - He wound up in the
company of some cantankerous reptile and a
Korean fox woman, an unlikely pair if ever
there was one.
After finding himself in a room with them,
he decided that they should have a little
more privacy, and dragged them back into his
pocket dimension for further fun.
Of course, with two at once, his attention
had been a little split.
They spent as much time tussling with each
other as resisting his attempts to torment
them.
They’d definitely put him through his paces
that day, and he gave far better than he got:
After so many hours of brutal mutilation,
there was barely any of the lizard left, despite
its frustrating insistence on quickly healing
from so many of its wounds.
Still, it was good exercise, even if the results
had been less than satisfying.
If he could get another anomaly alone, though,
he’d be able to take his time, and really
savor the pain he caused.
Oh, that sounded heavenly...
Soon, he came upon an incredibly strange containment
chamber that quickly caught his eye: It looked
like a huge, metal cube, with no way in or
out.
Not even a seam.
Whatever was trapped in there, the Old Man
thought, it must be something that even the
fools at the SCP Foundation really, truly
wanted nothing to do with.
But even more so than the strange sight, it
was the sound that drew the Old Man in, tempting
him like a siren song.
It was weeping.
A soft, sobbing keen that betrayed a bottomless
well of misery.
Whatever was making that crying sound had
known true despair.
Or, whatever passes for true despair before
you’ve had a close encounter with the Old
Man in his pocket dimension.
The Old Man grinned, and thought, “Oh, sonny,
I’ll give you something to really cry about...”
He stepped forward and phased his way into
the metal cube.
The creature was in the corner.
In contrast to that stupid lizard, this monster
was pleasingly humanoid, with, presumably,
all the familiar pain points.
Splendid.
The only real difference was color and proportion:
It was far longer and ganglier than an average
human, with greyish skin and no hair anywhere
on its body.
Still, it was something the Old Man could
work with.
The creature didn’t even seem to register
his presence, it just sat crumpled in the
corner, weeping.
Still grinning his lunatic grin, the Old Man
approached and rested a moist hand on the
creature’s shoulder.
Its pale skin began to fizzle from the intruder’s
corrosive touch.
A pool of vile sludge began spreading out
beneath his feet until the other creature
was encompassed too.
Little by little, they sank into the Old Man’s
favorite place out of the world: The Pocket
Dimension, his own personal, eternal, infinite
dungeon, where the only laws are pain and
terror for all but the Old Man himself.
Little did he know, this time, the scores
may be a little more even on that front.
There they both stood, in that terrible labyrinth
of hallways and chambers where the Old Man
had made countless lives infinitely worse
than any terrible afterlife that could follow
them, and still, this creature didn’t seem
to change its reaction.
He was almost irritated by it.
And what’s more, this whole time, the creature
hadn’t even turned to look at him.
He’d have to fix that, too.
The Old Man, with his shocking strength, gripped
the monster’s shoulder and whipped him around,
staring into his face, bearing his black eyes
and manic smile.
But he couldn’t help find what looked back
at him...
Disconcerting.
Its eyes were blank and white.
Its face, stretched and warped into a permanent
grimace, like Munch’s old painting, The
Scream.
And the second the Old Man laid eyes on it,
that’s exactly what it did.
Its gaping mouth let out the most terrible
wail the Old Man had ever heard in all his
years of torturing.
It was a scream of unknowable sadness and
fear.
But somehow, the Old Man sensed that this
creature didn’t fear him.
It feared itself.
Feared what it was about to do.
What the hell had he dragged down here with
him?
Without warning, the terrible wails soon gave
way to sudden and ferocious aggression - Just
like the Old Man had dealt out to a group
of Foundation guards and Mobile Task Force
agents earlier that same night.
It was only out of a mix of pure luck and
his own finely-tuned animal instinct that
the Old Man was able to dodge the first strike
from the creature’s long, lithe forelimb.
He couldn’t believe it.
They were in his special place, and this victim
of his had the audacity to fight back?
Well, he’d soon put this monster in its
place...
As the monster continued roaring and swiping
for him, the Old Man simply walked backwards
into a nearby wall, disappearing into a black
stain.
Of course, the monster - better known to the
SCP Foundation As SCP-096, or The Shy Guy,
simply crashed through the wall to give chase.
But on the other side...
Just another wall.
He’d disappeared.
How?
Typically, when something sees the face of
the Shy Guy, he immediately has a kind of
intuitive connection to them.
He can sense their presence, it’s burned
into his mind, a homing beacon, an unstoppable
imperative.
He knows exactly where they are and how to
get to them.
But nothing about this situation was typical.
The Shy Guy felt all the murderous rage he
normally did, but the rest was just static.
Where was the life he needed to abolish hiding?
Suddenly, the Old Man emerged behind him,
and forced his hand into the Shy Guy’s back.
His fist melted straight through flesh and
skin, causing the creature to let out another
terrible wail, but as could be expected, they
didn’t leave a scratch on the Shy Guy’s
indestructible skeleton.
The Shy Guy pulled a one-eighty and swung
for the Old Man again, but he was already
gone.
Here in the Pocket Dimension, the Old Man
had the ultimate home-turf advantage.
Here, space and time were his playthings.
In the infinite twisting, labyrinthine walls
of the Pocket Dimension, the Old Man wasn’t
just the Devil, he was God, too.
But it would take far more than some cheap
tricks and bodily harm to dissuade the Shy
Guy from his sole purpose in life.
It began running through the Old Man’s personal
maze like a crazed lab rat, tearing through
wall after wall, forever searching for the
monster that trapped it here.
It would see the smiling face of that rotten
old man every so often, the flash of black
eyes and dirty teeth in shadows, but every
time it tried to strike the shadows, there
would be nothing there.
And every time he got a chance, the Old Man
would emerge from the shadows behind the Shy
Guy to strike back, clawing into his flesh
and vanishing again before the trapped beast
could retaliate.
The nasty old sadist was now starting to have
some fun: It was a reflex test, a classic
game of high-stakes Whack A Mole.
And every time the creature failed to strike
him, its distress only seemed to grow.
This was perfectly fine for the Old Man.
After all, he enjoyed a little mental torment
as much as he loved physical torture, and
a human would have died or given in to despair
long before now.
This monster’s wonderful mix of resilience
and pain made it a great chew toy.
The Old Man kept up this routine, baiting
and striking, until something unanticipated
happened.
He appeared, waited for the swing, disappeared
as it approached, then reappeared behind the
Shy Guy to deliver another painful strike.
This time, however, it seemed his victim had
anticipated his pattern.
Before he could hit the creature, the Shy
Guy turned, quicker than anything the Old
Man had ever seen, and hit him with such force
he flew through several walls in his own maze,
shattering them as he went.
He hit the ground, stunned by the fact the
Shy Guy had actually landed a hit, but he
wasn’t done.
The shrieking monster came bounding after
him.
Before the Old Man could stand, it struck
him again, and again, and again, pounding
his vile body into the ground, which cracked
and crumbled.
The Old Man sneered and sank into a puddle
of his mucus on the ground.
The Old Man was gone again.
SCP-096 screamed in a mix of rage, despair,
and frustration, so consumed with its hunt
that it didn’t notice the pool of corrosive
mucus was slowly growing.
It began to rise, bubbling and hissing at
SCP-096’s feet.
Getting deeper and deeper and deeper, as the
walls rose taller and taller around it.
The creature wailed, until a tide of the awful
stuff reached its face and cascaded down its
throat, melting all the organs within.
As the creature was fully submerged, SCP-106
manifested atop the wall, and looked down,
smiling spitefully.
He thought, oh, you may think you had me there,
boy-o, but in the end, I always win.
Nothing could survive that!
And yet, bubbles still rose from the slop
below.
The Old Man gritted his rotten teeth and balled
his fists in quiet anger.
Moments later, back in our dimension, a portal
opened in the ground of SCP-096’s containment
chamber.
It vomited out SCP-096’s skeleton, smothered
in bubbling black goo, and SCP-106.
096 would probably be fully regenerated within
a couple of hours - and if 682’s encounter
with him was anything to go by, probably extremely
unwilling to interface with the Old Man.
And the Old Man himself, who couldn’t help
but feel a little humiliated by the whole
experience, was glad the two of them would
probably never meet again.
He left the regenerating 096 and commenced
the walk of shame back to his containment
chamber.
They didn’t even need the femur breaker,
he just felt like having a sit-down and processing
it all.
Nobody else would ever know what happened
in the pocket dimension that day, and for
the Old Man’s pride, that was probably for
the best.
But he’d know.
He’d always know.
By the night’s end, he was sitting in his
containment chamber again, forlornly wondering,
“Goddamn it, old-timer, have you lost your
edge?”
Now go check out “SCP-096 - Look at a Picture
of Shy Guy in Space?
The Shy Guy Questions and Theories” and
“SCP-106 - The Old Man Origin Theories”
for more videos on today’s terrifying combatants!